listen i i hate to do this with fox news
but i was at fox news for four and a
half years
my own interviews that i would do on fox
news at this point i maybe had 50 000
subscribers on youtube
were removed when i would ask hey can i
upload them i said sure and they said
you know what we actually don't want
these things going on youtube because we
don't think it has the longevity
and now of course you see it's one of
the very few conservative outlets
that's consistently featured on youtube
because they have that buying power
and they're trying to play catch up this
is really about legacy media
being behind the eight ball and making
up for it with dollars
and what we would what i would like to
see this isn't this doesn't relate to
our legal case but
um this relates to the ecosystem look
youtube will never be netflix
and if they want to understand their
business model and how they survive
it's not by letting legacy media try and
corporatize youtube right
it's by focusing on and supporting their
content creators
but all of these you know turner nbc
universal
disney abc there's really about five
companies
they will do anything they can to remove
competition
and i think it was never like bill has
said it's never been a plan of this
strategy it
sort of was accidental with the vox
apocalypse though remember we found out
afterwards we're like why are they
reaching out to us turns out that
alphabet took a nosedive their stock
after the vox apocalypse
because a lot of people were upset and
you know sometimes the market puts
people between a rock and a hard place
where it's okay either appease the
people who work
in your pal in your northern california
offices or
piss off half of the most powerful
nation on earth
right and that's where they often find
themselves crowder when that
adpocalypse thing happened and it had a
lot to do with you got into a little
skirmish with this carlos mazza guy
from from vox who happened to be the
same guy
who lobbied pete bootaj to not do my
show
and you know runs around calling
everyone white supremacists
and and the rest of it does that
asymmetry drive you nuts that
they can say whatever they want about us
all the time we know that
and they can do whatever damage they
want to our businesses but then
and i uh correct me if i'm wrong but i'm
pretty sure he's like a
you know like a privileged partner or
whatever they call it on youtube
while he can say whatever he wants about
us but if we were to do the same with
him
you you lost your ad rev for what a year
on youtube
more than a year right i don't know
exactly what it was i will tell you this
though to be fair um i never really
focused on on that guy
and i hate to correct you but really
this was just
one of or several videos in a series of
criticisms of vox you know vox would do
the explain series
so we criticized vox all the time just
like we do with john oliver just like we
do with vice
just like we would do a slate and this
was really kind of edited out of context
what it was for me
my problem there was nbc universal
vox one of the most powerful companies
in the world who also happen to have a
lot of advertising
uh dollars that they spend with a
company like youtube
um trying to get the independent content
creator removed and by the way also they
co-produce a show
on youtube and and vox along with
there's licensing agreements with
netflix so
for me it was really important and i
think this resonated with people as
opposed to individuals
um it was a david versus goliath where
it's like look it's easy to say hey
we have a big following and a big show
but we've built this over
years and nbc universal vox is trying to
take that away because
they were late to the party they wanted
to keep everything off of youtube we
were there when they were copyright
claiming everything
and not putting anything on youtube and
then they wanted to compete and not to
you know listen
i i hate to do this with fox news but i
was at fox news for four and a half
years
my own interviews that i would do on fox
news at this point i maybe had 50 000
subscribers on youtube
were removed when i would ask hey can i
upload them i said sure and they said
you know what we actually don't want
these things going on youtube because we
don't think it has the longevity
and now of course you see it's one of
the very few conservative outlets
that's consistently featured on youtube
because they have that buying power
and they're trying to play catch-up this
is really about legacy media
being behind the eight ball and making
up for it with dollars
and what we would what i would like to
see this isn't this doesn't relate to
our legal case but
um this relates to the ecosystem look
youtube will never be netflix
and if they want to understand their
business model and how they survive
it's not by letting legacy media try and
corporatize youtube right
it's by focusing on and supporting their
content creators
but all of these you know turner nbc
universal
disney abc there's really about five
companies
they will do anything they can to remove
competition
what's brian stelter gonna do compete
with you compete with me
honestly i still want i still want to
know what that guy did to get a show
chris cuomo
get his brother's governor good-looking
guy brian stelter is untalented
unattractive and uninformed and he gets
a show
with no experience well what's he gonna
that's why that guy
more aggressively than any other on-air
host lobbies
to have people removed and de-platformed
on a regular basis it's because they're
afraid of competition
so do you think you could ever get to
the the point of popularity numbers
monetization whatever you want to call
it that you would just be like
all right i i don't want to do the legal
route anymore we're not getting anywhere
or it's a strain and stress and
everything else and i'm
i'm just going to be free meaning i'll
be on the blaze
or whatever else there might be um and
just not deal
with this nonsense i could probably do
that
now in the sense that if i just we're
just talking about surviving and keeping
my people employed
i could probably do that now because we
have a lot of people who support us and
who join up with
with mug club um but uh we've always
said that we want to make sure that
um you know the supported content is
what
allows the free content you know for me
my goal is always to have as many people
out there
who at least are whether or not they're
conservative uh
free speech advocates you know for me
i'm a simple guy i am pretty
pretty right wing but first amendment
second amendment especially coming from
a country that
has neither canada are pretty important
to me to give you an analogy and i've
always talked about this where i'm i'm
i'm big into firearms but i'm not a
collector i'm not a maven what i would
rather see out there
are 50 people with one firearm than one
person with 50.
i want more people comfortable around
firearms those who've taken basic
firearm safety courses who understand
how firearms work because
once that happens you know you can no
longer have joe biden go up and say
an ar-14 is a sim is a machine gun first
off you meant ar15 not 14
and it's not a machine gun it's a
semi-automatic just like any other
handgun
so for me it's really important to be on
youtube and be on facebook and be on
twitter
to reach new people and to create new
free speech advocates and new
firearm owners new conservatives people
who will understand what this country
was
was founded on and and continue those
values forward so could i leave
take my ball and go home and and make
enough to live comfortably with the
people who will support us
probably but we're not going to be
reaching any new hearts and minds so for
as long as i can be
on those platforms and even if i'm just
a thorn in their side
uh that's a good thing that tells me
that we're reaching a lot of folks
yeah i'm with you bill what about just
the the culture of fear
around lawyers i i sort of hit on this
earlier but just when
when you're talking to your colleagues
or other people at your firm or
or just when you're talking to crowders
fans i mean
you got to be somewhat afraid that
they're going to bust into all of your
emails and
whatever else whatever else we can think
they can do and probably what's worse is
the stuff that we can't imagine they can
do
there's certainly a concern about that i
do get a lot of communications from
folks i think the ones that are the
the most damning of where we've come as
a culture
is when i get emails from law schools
across the country from law students
and i get instagram messages and tweets
and sometimes calls and they're just
like
wow i can't say anything about this i
can't remotely show that i'm
conservative there are a few that are
willing to do it and they pay the price
for it
i'm just going to get my degree work
quietly and move along the number of
folks who
you know i show up and they go oh wow
they sent me an email i go i didn't even
realize that you were conservative you
just never came up in
committee meetings or organization
meetings or at a you know bar function
or whatnot
and because of that culture of fear and
it to a certain extent you just have to
say
it's okay i'm gonna accept whatever
might come that come down that pike
and deal with it because you know when
you're dealing with these companies
that's certainly gonna happen you know
fortunately for me we've got
a broad base of different clients and
different folks who are supportive and
really just say
great lawyers i don't care let's hire
them let's go get it done i think the
folks like steven have to really step
out on a limb and have along with other
folks who are even willing to talk about
these types of things
knowing that all of the strings are
controlled uh out of menlo park in palo
alto and you know what
on that note you know for example um
gina karan i can say this now because
it's public look i've known this for a
very long time about gina carrano jeanna
crano's followed me we've invited gina
carrano on the show and she has
watched the show i i can't do it so now
i think we'll probably have in the show
and by the way she decided to appear on
ben shapiro show but one thing ben
shapiro can't claim
is an actual teenage crush on gina karan
i was at brown belt and jujitsu people
know i come by it honestly and i used to
watch every single gina carano fight
including her getting manhandled by
cyborg who tested positive for steroids
where effectively dinarena was fighting
a man
not named fallon fox but i digress wait
hold on hold on you're saying
ben shapiro is not a brown belt in jiu
jitsu shapiro didn't know gina carrano
until this happened unless he's a star
wars nerd i followed gina carrano when
she was
fighting in the future uh but i can tell
you right now
off the top of my head i could give you
another eight to ten gina karanos
actually
and some other people including people
in the sport of mma including people who
would be
current top 10 paid in hollywood
who would never come out and i would
never out them they're still out there
but i can tell you gina carrano was one
of them and i certainly hope that we
have on the show but that's so
sad to me because the thing about gina
carrano i think this was a bigger story
than people even realized because yeah
you have a lot of people have been
de-platformed
but there are a lot of sort of
conservatives who guilty
uh abrasive and they're easier to hate i
think when people actually tune into
what we do they understand that
people sort of go well this is actually
basic pitch conservatism the heart in
this is really not malicious at all
but gina carano was the first example of
someone who was not really outwardly
political
and nothing she said in any capacity
could be interpreted as
malicious there was no malice to any of
it as a matter of fact
and i think that generally speaking uh
holocaust
or hitler comparisons are ill-advised i
think she was as thoughtful and as
tactful with
that post as one could be because she
wasn't saying it's like being a jew
being a conservative
uh in hollywood which she was saying is
it started by having your neighbors
snitch on neighbors and i think that's
the important thing people use this term
sort of cancel culture
and it didn't exist by the way i pitched
the book for change my mind i've talked
about this many times to conservative
publishers
and there was no canceled culture so i
had these but i described sjws
i described leftist activists and i
described people who are sort of liberal
by default
and sort of what ended up becoming the
alt-right and i just had different words
for it and every single publisher turned
it down and said this book is silly no
one will ever want to do it
change my mind book um but what's so
crazy about this i don't want to say
crazy what really makes me sad is
when people say good good for good for
gina carano being removed and you look
at the content
of what it is that she said that's
people saying good i hope you
never have the ability to provide for
your family again
this is desensitizing people this could
easily be desensitizing people
towards something much more sinister not
saying it is not saying that's part of
some
some conspiracy plan but when people are
saying
cancel that person and they're
supporting it they're supporting the
ending
of people's livelihoods which by the way
is exactly what they're doing
with covet lockdowns in businesses and
saying how much is your life worth
hold on a second you're talking about a
0.17
whatever it is death rate which by the
way is the exact number that those
california doctors were
banned for communicating on facebook and
youtube because at that point it was the
imperial college of london saying
it was a two to four percent death rate
hold on a second you're saying how much
is my life worth because
we have 60 percent of businesses now
that have been that'll be open in april
that won't be open in september right
how much is a livelihood worth people
right now are so quick to go along
with removing someone's ability to
provide for their family
forever and if you get people okay with
that i don't think it's that much of a
leap to say that you get opaque
you get desensitized to dehumanizing
people um
to any degree if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about comedy instead of the non-stop
yelling you get everywhere else check
out our comedy playlist and if you want
to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell